alright let's see I think this is the
I'm supposed to stop two minutes ago but
then you know you just get a chance to
get everyone into the room that's my
excuse and I'm sticking with that my
name is Marc seaman and if you want to
know more about me there's information
there and block uploader decays I'm not
going to tire you with that also I on
twitter at blur so apart from being a
freelance software developer I also give
conference talks like this one so a
couple of months ago I was in Kiev in
Ukraine giving a conference talk there
and I was talking about what we can
learn about dependency injection from
functional programming languages like if
sharp and haskell it's not that it's not
the talk that I'm giving today was
another one and after the talk people
came to me and started talking to me
which is a perfectly normal thing you're
welcome to do that as well and one of
the common questions that I you know
kept getting was okay so you showed us
all those cool things in the shop and in
Haskell how do you apply those things in
c-sharp I'm sort of thinking a little
bit about the the answer to this problem
what is the question
and I basically beginning to arrive at
the conclusion that it's fine that she's
job is getting some of the functional
language features like lambda
expressions and stuff like that but
trying to turn she sharp into a you know
strictly statically typed functional
programming language is not really gonna
take your codebase to a place where you
want to be people weren't really happy
with that answer because you often need
you obviously you'd like to get an
answer that you know you can do these
things but okay that's what that's the
best I could come up with at that time
so I gave another talk I actually
repeated the talk in Moscow a month
later on and afterwards people came and
asked me various questions and one of
the questions that kept coming up was
you know how do you apply all those cool
techniques she shops you can sort of see
a pattern this is a question that I get
asked over and over again and again you
know I answer that well you can do some
things but you know really trying to go
fully functional in c-sharp it's not
gonna make it's not
you can't you can't harvest the benefits
of functional programming by doing that
and she sharp because it's gonna make
your code look absolutely horrible and
people they didn't really believe me so
I decided okay I will now show the world
just how horrible it can be and that's
the talk today I kid you not that's
that's my plan I will show you the most
horrible c-sharp code you have seen now
you've probably seen her horrible Etsy
shop code but I won't show you horrible
shop code in a completely different way
of horror if you will so you know let's
do that we need to look at some example
code so I always like to use the same
scenario for my examples if I can and
that of an online restaurant reservation
system this I always use this scenario
if at all possible but I keep you know
we remix thing and changing the code
examples so just to make sure everyone
understands what we're talking about you
want to make a restaurant reservation
you go to if you find a form you fill in
the dates and your details and so on
this is my real Emma trees email it's
all the spammers already have it so you
will come to use it as well so you fill
in the form you click Submit it creates
some sort of JSON document and that gets
posted to some sort of web server and
they think that we have to do is we have
to figure out how to implement the web
server and we're just going to look at a
small snippet of the business logic they
are not even the entire web server stack
and we just see what's gonna happen if
we try to make it fully functional and
sticking in c-sharp now since we're
doing a dependency injection I think
this is a good you know thing to see if
we can turn that into a fully functional
thing we will define an interface
because that's what you do when you do a
dependency injection you could use an
abstract base class as well that's not
really important so we we really have a
database with some reservations inside
of them but in order to comply with
various enterprise things we call it
repository even though everyone knows
it's a database so here's our database
well with the real reservations inside
of them and there's a couple of things
we can do we can query the database read
all the reservations that are already
registered in that database for a
particular date gives us a collection of
resumes
it's back you can create a new row in
the database you'll notice I'm using the
create read update and delete
terminology here I'll just stick with
those two methods though the reservation
method or the create method returns an
integer that is the idea of the row that
it you know that you just created in the
database so this violates the command
query separation principle but it's a
common thing that people do so I'm just
keeping the example here realistic now I
want to add a third method just to make
things a little bit more interesting and
the third one it's not really doesn't
really belong here but lets this add it
anyway so we want to be able to figure
out whether there is a reservation is in
the future in the past because we can't
doesn't make sense to accept a
reservation for a date in the past now
this really belongs this method really
belongs on a different interface a
different abstraction but we'll just put
it on on this reservation repository for
the sake of the example otherwise it's
got check cannot get way too complicated
okay so if we if we assume that we kind
of take that you know repository and
inject into some sort of class we can
now try to make a little bit of a
business decision of whether we can
accept the reservation or not so we'll
have an incoming reservation and we'll
try to figure out whether we can accept
it so it will return an honorable int
and the contract here is based the idea
is that if we accept the reservation we
will have created a new row in the
database and that reel has an ID and
that becomes the idea of the reservation
and we'll just return that if for some
reason we have to reject the reservation
we'll return null so the first thing we
could do if we have a we if we injected
this repository from before into the
class and Elvia the constructor and then
we could access it and we could say is
reservation in future that returns boo
if that pool is false we'll return null
immediately we know that we can't accept
that that was some sort of input
validation error that failed there
otherwise we can move on we can query
the database we can say read
reservations with the reservation date
that gives us a collection of
reservations we'll just do a sum over
the quantities that gives me an integer
that is the number of reserved seats for
that particular date so I'm sort of
ignoring that there may be tables that
are not completely filled so you can
imagine this is one of those fancy
restaurants that just has one big table
and they
one has to you know dine community
together it's probably in New York
somewhere right so we have a number we
need to figure out whether we have
enough remaining capacity so if we know
the capacity of the restaurant that's
another number we can make our business
decision we can say if we have too
little remaining capacity of the
capacity that we have is less than the
number of reserved seats plus the
requested quantity there and we also
reject the reservation and we do that by
returning null but otherwise we can move
on we can set this acceptor to true
we'll call the create method on the
repository that creates a row in the
database
it returns on i.t we just return that ID
c-sharp has an implicit inverse
conversion between int and na level of
int so this compile this works and gets
the job done there's nothing wrong with
with this at all
so in in an effort to make things more
complicated that they can't be as
someone would then say but how do we do
this with functional programming so
let's let's have a look at that before I
launch into this whole thing I want to
make a little detour because the detour
will hopefully be instructive so here's
the reservation repository interface
again I reordered the methods a little
bit I put reservation in the future on
top because this is the order that we
actually end up using him so maybe this
is a little bit more intuitive I hope
when you're interacting with the
database what you're really doing is i/o
so you might want to say let's make it
async this is not really what I want to
do for the rest of the talk but this
will be in you know instructive I hope
so we can see what happens if we make it
a sync basically what you need to do to
make it async is that you're just
instead of returning you know normal
values you just return tasks of those
things so tasks a pool tasks of a
reservation collection tasks of int so
with modern c-sharp you know that's not
really a big change because you just
take your try/except method from before
and you just sprinkle east sync and
await keywords in in the right places
and then it still works there's a
magical you know language feature there
but
thing is the TPL you know the task
parallel library that technology existed
before the async and await keyword were
introduced into the language so before
you had a Singh in a wait you could
still write this code but it wouldn't
look like this it would look something
like this so what you would need to do
is you would say well okay let's call
his reservations in future with the
reservation now that's going to return a
task of bool so that's not what we want
we want a task of novel ind so we can't
really move on until that task has
completed processing so what you need to
do is you need to call a method called
continue with and you can see it happens
to be three times here and continue with
the idea here is that you now have to
supply a code block that you know tells
you know your code what happens when
that task has completed so you get a
task in its completed state as input
into the code block that you supply so
t1 t2 and t3 there those are completed
tasks so what you can do is and what
I've done here is you I continue with
the code block in the form of a lambda
expression so t1 for example is the
completed task that that Compaq comes
back when is reservation in future has
evaluated so what you can do then you
can say t1 that result that's a boolean
value and then you can do normally if
things on that one and t2 that resolve
further on down for example that's a
task of reservation collection so you
know taking the result out of that will
just give you the reservations and so
forth so this idea about having a step a
task and then you know after the task is
completed you tell the code what
happenes to happen next and the way you
do that is you supply a function or a
you know a piece of code that sort of
handles you know what happens next
so you'll notice one thing the output of
the task becomes the input to the
continuation so t1 for example is the
completed task the result of that is a
boolean value so the output of you know
figuring out what the time is or whether
the reservation is the future becomes
the input to the continuation and that's
the same pattern that goes our
you know in all three cases here so the
code becomes more complicated but this
is basically what we need to do when we
want to shift into doing something in a
functional style so we will have not
tasks of T but you know something of T
and we will sort of need to do
continuation passing style in this way
where we say we'll start something and
then when that completes we will have a
continuation function that takes the
result of the previous steps as input
and then continues with that so that's
sort of the intuition so this is just
why I wanted to show you this before we
got started with the real functional
stuff now how do i do dependency
injection in haskell well you don't
because SQL is a functional language
fine it's functional how do i inject
dependencies well you use a free monad
which allows you to build a monad for
any functor did you just tell me to go
myself even dead Bob
so apart from being funny
and there's a there's quite a bit of
truth in this little comic here because
first of all it's true that if you ask a
certain category of functional
programmers they will give you that
answer and they will just expect you to
understand what they say and they will
expect you to understand what is a free
monad what is a functor so in that level
that answer is usually not particularly
useful but another thing about this is
that it's actually true this is how you
do dependency injection in Haskell
what's one of them there's a couple of
different alternative options there but
it's one of them so you can absolutely
use a free monent in order to model you
know how that works so I'm just gonna be
that guy and just launch into do free
monads in c-sharp how about that it's
not gonna be fun
so I'm not expecting you to know what a
free monad is I'm not expecting you to
really know what a functor is although
that's pretty easy we'll get to that in
a moment what my really what my agenda
here is I'm trying to show you know what
it'll actually what will happen if you
try to go all the way to functional
programming in a language like C sharp
so let's see what we can do here so we
have this repository interface there
and we want to figure out how to do this
in the functional style so if we want to
turn it into a free monad there's
actually a recipe so I'm not really
gonna try to explain to you if one of
three Monette is I'm just gonna show you
that there is a an automatable process
for translating a c-sharp interface like
this one into a free moon and it goes in
a lot of steps so if you if you really
want to know all the details I have a
blog post that walks you through this in
very elaborate details but basically
what you need to do is you have to start
trying to figure out how to turn and rip
you know an interface like this into a
functor so what's a functor well you
probably know link entry shop already
you have you know a list of integers and
you know you can call you know select on
that and then if you say you know for
each of the integers inside of that list
of integers I'm just going to turn that
into a string now you have a list of
strings instead of a list of int so that
ability to take a container of something
and turn it into a container of some
other generic type that is basically
what a functor means it doesn't have to
be much more complicated than that and
she's sharp already have the Lang has
the language feature to do that because
link was built around this idea about
you know functors monads and so so the
list select method is the what we call
this structure preserving translation of
this stuff inside of the container so so
we need to figure out how to do that
this is not a functor at the moment so
the trick is to say the three methods
defined by this interface we're going to
turn those into a little domain-specific
language and the the vocabulary of that
language will be those three methods so
it's not going to be a Turing complete
language it's going to be a very little
limited small domain-specific language
that just consists of three instructions
so the first thing we do what I'm not
going to do now is I'm kind of translate
off I'm going to follow my recipe for
translating this into f-sharp and again
I'm not assuming that you can
necessarily reach this sharp F sharp but
the syntax here I'm just going to use
some type declaration syntax I'm
actually not going to write you know
functions so that's that's gonna be okay
I hope I'll talk you through it now
following the recipe this is almost like
an automatical recipe what we do is we
say we
to create a new type this new type
should be generic will not we'll call it
something a little bit different because
we'll typically call it something
instruction in this case I decided to
call it reservations instructions and
this Prime a this is just the f-sharp
syntax for writing a generic type
argument so in c-sharp this would have
been capital letter t but here's here
it's a now the next step in in this
recipe that you can follow and you can
probably write a program that did this
for you if you wanted to is to say well
for each of the methods in the interface
you create a case so what you're
starting to do here is what we call a
discriminative Union something that can
be one of multiple mutually exclusive
cases so the first case we just take the
first method and turn that into a case
and the name of the case is just the
name of the method so we just call that
case it's preservation in the future and
when you're creating when you're trying
to turn an interface like this into a
little DSL which has to be a functor the
contents of the each case will always
have to be a tuple so this is how you
create tuples I left some space that so
that we can you know have some some type
annotations there and but it's just the
brackets just say the here comes a tuple
and the star in the middle just means
that that's the delimiter between the
types in the tuple and the recipe then
says that the input value or the input
type of the method that we are mapping
at the moment should be the first tuple
so we'll just say that it's going to be
a tuple by the first element is a
reservation and then the second element
in the tuple should be a continuation
function so remember I showed you this
TBL example would continue with before
where you know after you've completed
one step you continue with something
else so the idea here is that we have
sort of abstracted away the idea of
figuring out whether a reservation is in
the future and we can delegate that to
some sort of interpreter of our little
domain-specific language later on and
then when the interpreter you know is
done interpreting it'll call our
continuation function with the result of
what it figured out so that means that
just like in the TPL example the output
of our our little operation there
especially in the future becomes the
input to the continuation function and
then the continuation function should
take that as
input and return a value of the generic
type a now if you didn't get all of this
this is perfectly okay I'm just trying
to demonstrate to you that I'm following
a recipe here there's you don't have to
think in order to do this you can
basically just write a program that did
that if you want it to so we'll just
continue on with the next one I'll move
a little faster now so we know that read
reservations also has to be a tuple and
the second element has to be a function
that takes that returns the generic type
a so we'll take the date/time offset
which is the input to the method and
we'll make that the first element of the
tuple and then we'll say the output the
read-only collection of reservation
there we'll just turn that into a
reservation list and that will be the
input to the continuation function and
we'll map the create method in the same
way there's a case called a create it
takes a tuple or the content inside of
that it's a tuple of create of
reservation and a continuation function
that goes from in to a so again you know
if you don't if you're not entirely
following this it's okay the real point
is to show you that this is actually
translatable back in to C sharp and I'll
show you how to do this in a moment but
you're not going to like the result so
let's remove the interface there and see
what we have so far now in F sharp this
is called a discriminated union so the
idea of a discriminated union is it's a
type that statically is known to have in
this case three mutually exclusive sub
cases or subtypes if you will so you can
think of it a little bit like an object
hierarchy but the difference is that
it's not extensible it is very
deliberately not extensible so we know
that there's only gonna be those three
cases and not only do we know that they
compiler knows that as well so whenever
we whenever we have a value of that type
you know if if we call a function and we
get that as a return value in order to
do anything with with the type of that
nature we have to deal with all of the
three cases we sort of have to handle
all three cases and if we don't do that
the compiler will tell us and you can
actually make the compiler you know not
you know refuse to compile if you
haven't handled all three things so it
enables us to be really
we can write some really robust code and
because we can have compile time
checking of whether we've dealt with all
all the edge cases as well so in general
this is known as a some type and
functional programmers really love this
because it enables them to make states
on legal states unrepresentable
this is a catch phrase that you will
hear functional programmers say I talk
about over and over it was coined by
Aaron Minsky who writes in oh camel
another you know statically typed
functional programming language but we
do it in if sharp all the time in the
next time start I believe Scott lation
will be talking about something maybe
you'll hear him say it he often says
that with good reason
Aeschylus will do the same thing as well
so and you may also know Scott blah shin
in the next talk will never be schmuck
but you may you know sometimes you never
encounter those functional programmers
that can be a little overbearing and say
well we can make it legal state
sovereign visit representable what about
you object-oriented programs can you do
that ha ha and then and then you say
because you've been to this talk you say
well yes we can because we can just use
Church encoding all right okay so this
is Alonzo Church he's the inventor of
the lambda calculus and he didn't come
up with this idea of church encoding
himself but he came up with a way to
encode or describe mutually exclusive
things as functions and then later on
program has sort of figured out that the
way that he could do that in lambda
calculus actually translates pretty well
into code and therefore we call it
church encoding after him but he was a
mathematician he was not a programmer so
let's see how that works so we have this
thing we sort of started on the work of
doing a free Monette now I'm gonna post
that recipe I'm gonna put it aside a
little well I'm gonna pick up another
recipe and this is the recipe for
turning discriminated unions into church
encoded c-sharp code so there's a recipe
for that as well and you can basically
just you know think of it as a paper and
you just follow the recipe so how do we
do that well we'll take the name of the
type and we'll turn it into an interface
and here you can see that it's an AI
reservation instruction of T so that you
know prime a of that just becomes
capital letter T so that's the generic
type argument and then you take each of
the cases oh I need to do something
the next thing you do is you know that
interface always has one method and it's
you could call it match it doesn't
really matter you know exactly what it's
called but there are reasons why it
might be a good idea to call it match
and you'll notice that is this is
generic as well but its generic on the
on the method level not on the type
level so there's already two different
generic types involved here
te on the type and T result on the
method itself so match must return a T
result value so what you do now is you
for each of the cases in your
discriminated union you add an argument
to this method so what we do first is
that we take is reservations in future
and we add that as an argument and the
recipe says that the arguments should be
a function that takes something and
returns a t result value so we do that
for each reservation in future you'll
notice that I have lowercase D I there
so that it looks like a none argument
and not and not a case anymore so we do
that for the other two things read
reservations should be a function from
something to T result and create should
be a function from something to T
results so the idea here is that when
you have an object of that interface you
don't know which of the three cases it
actually is and in order to do anything
with it you have to supply three
functions that will handle each of the
three cases now only one of those three
functions are ever going to be executed
but you don't know which one it is
so you have to supply all three so that
you cover all all the cases so all of
those functions you will notice returns
T results so this is how you can sort of
pull you know data out of of a
discriminated Union in C sharp and still
have compile time support so what what
should go into the you can see that sort
of left a placeholder there for you know
the input into those functions so what
what needs to go there well what needs
to go there is the data that is
contained inside of each of those cases
so we actually need more it turns out we
need more room so I'm just ordering
things around a little bit and you'll
notice that the is read reservations
thing actually overflows to the right so
you can't even see all of it and it's
okay it's gonna be horrible and you know
this you don't need to see all of it to
see just horrible it's
be so what's going to be the input
things well in all three cases up there
we have two bulls so we can say all of
all of them are going to be two bulls
and the first element of the first tuple
is a reservation value so we can just
you know map that over the second one is
at a time offset value and the third one
is a reservation value so again you can
see I'm following a mechanical process
I'm not really I don't really have to
think and I was really happy when I did
this because you know I actually did
couldn't understand what was going on so
I said I'll just take this one and put
it there and okay that compiles okay
fine so um so that's that's there but
then the second element of the tuple we
need to figure out what to do about that
as well so you notice that they're all
functions so we'll say this needs to be
a func and then all three of them are
functions that return the generic type a
its you know down in our shop code we
call that T so we'll just sit and say
that's gonna be the return type and
again you can't see the middle T because
it's sitting out here towards the right
but it doesn't read it it's not really
that important so now we're not just
need to figure out what's got to be the
input to those continuation functions
well in the first case it's a bow in the
second it's an REO in a collection of is
vation and then in third case it's an
int so that's the first step of doing
church encoding and if you think already
that this looks horrible I agree I mean
this is not something when you know if
you just showed people to this if you
just show this to someone and says well
usually shop developer can you tell me
what's going on here what no I that
makes no sense
it's a funk of a tuple of something and
then inside of that funk there's another
thing or what so we maybe we should you
know shield ourselves a little bit and
just sort of block them out and sort of
just think about them as you know blobs
of data
so I'll just block them out with three
colors and don't put any don't try to
interpret there anything from those
colors you know it doesn't mean that
rate one is bad and the green one is
good it's just so that we can
distinguish them from from each other so
we sort of hiding the details there and
just sort of try to figure out whether
we can do so we have three functions
that
from either the rate with data blob or
the yellow data type or the green data
type Tootsie result so the next thing we
do we need to do when we don't want to
do Church encoding is that we have to
create an implementation of this
interface for each of the three cases so
we'll just start with the first one and
say let's create a class called s
reservation in future it has to
implement the interface now what it'll
do is it'll take a tuple of reservation
and func and blah blah okay that's the
red one there this is basically an
adapter over the red data type you know
an adapter that you know design pattern
from in the Gang of Four book where it
says well if you have an object of one
type and you want to make it look like
an object of a different type you can
create a little wrapper class that you
know makes makes it look like it's the
other thing this is basically what we're
doing here we have this whatever that
red blob is and we just make it look
like it's an eye reservation instruction
of T so in order to implement the
interface we have to implement this
horrible-looking match method there and
again we'll block the things out so that
we don't have to think about exactly
what's going on and then we'll have to
figure out okay so how do we implement
this now we have to return a value of T
result and we have three functions to
choose from and a rate and a value of
the red data type so we have a function
that goes from the red data type to T
basalt we have another function that
goes from the yellow data type to T
result and one that goes from the green
data type to achieve assault now the
only thing we can really do here is just
to say well the function that goes from
the the red data type into T
result is reservation in the future that
will work you know if we call that if we
dispatch you know execution back to that
one by just passing in the tuple then
it's kind of return achieve resolve and
this is going to type check so that's
probably okay when you do generic
programming like this it's basically in
you know when it type checks it's
usually also correct so we do that with
this with the same we do the same thing
with the other two in this case I'm just
always dispatching back into is
reservation in the future this is the
function that the caller provides that
will handle that particular case of
those three cases and we do the same
thing with the other
here's an adapter over the yellow dancer
you'll notice that it always you know
calls or always dispatches back to read
reservations and the third class is an
adapter over the green dancer and it
always dispatches back into the create
function that handler there so we can
unmask this again if you think that's
helpful I don't think it's helpful but
it compiles and it gets us towards where
we want to go but pretty it isn't now
what we have at so far here is we have a
generic type now what the overbearing
character there said is that we needed
to create a free monad from a functor so
is this a functor well if functor this
idea of a function it's just like you
know ienumerable that you can sort of
map over it so basically the idea is
that if you have an IRA I reservations
destruction of tea can we turn it into
an i reservations instruction of tea
result well if we have a function that
takes it turns T values into T resolved
values that is now if we can do that
that's then it's probably a functor
turns out that we can so the way that we
need to do that is we have to create a
select method this is just like the
Select methods that are defined by for I
know mobile of T and we make it a an
extension method on I reservations
instruction of of T and then we just by
convention we call that function at the
third lock the second argument there we
just call that the selector all right so
how do we implement something like this
so again you know functional programmers
will basically tell you that when you
have when you're working with statically
typed functional programming like this
you just what they say follow the types
you sort of just look at the generic
types and have you if you can figure out
how to connect things so that the
compiler that all everything type checks
you've probably done it right so let's
see what we can do first of all we have
source the only thing we can do with
source is we can call match because that
interface only defines that single
method so we don't really have any
choice that's what we need to do and
because this is char compiler can't
really figure out what it is that we're
trying to do we have to you know it put
this type annotation on and say we want
to return an i reservations
nfg result all right so when you're
calling the match mess at them you have
to supply a function that will handle
each of the three cases so we can do
that as a lambda expression so that's
what I'm going to do so the first one
handles the East Reservation in future
case and I'm just starting the lambda
expression here so again the T is is
what's inside that case this is a tuple
that read tuple that we looked at before
that isn't particularly easy to think
about but but that's what it is so you
get a tubeless input and what you have
to do is you have to produce an i
reservations instruction of T result so
so how do we do that well you have three
classes that implements that interface
and when we're talking about functors we
have to do what we call a structure
preserving translation and that means
that you know you can't jump between the
cases if you're already in this case
that's called is reservation in the
future you have to stay in that case so
that's that basically limits our options
quite a bit so we'll just create a
newest reservation in future of TV
assault and then you know if you just
try to type this out in in visual studio
if that constructor will say but if you
want to have one of those you know you
have me must supply a tuple where the
first one is a reservation and the
second one is a function that you can't
see because it's overflowing we'll get
back to that in a moment
now the tuple again requires you to fill
some data into the tuple and the first
answer you have to put in is a
reservation value and we can do that by
just saying T item 1 because T is a
tuple with first item in the tuple is a
reservation value so you just copy that
over that was easy
now the second one is a little bit
harder what needs to go here is a func
from pool to tier assault so how can we
produce one of those well we could write
a lambda expression so I know that we're
writing a lambda expression inside of a
lambda expression yeah that's what we
sort of end up doing so we could write a
lambda expression that starts with a
boolean value
so B here would be a boolean value so at
least this is a function bool so now
we're not just need to figure out how we
produce the T result from
so what can we do with boolean values
here well we have a func from pool to
tea
that's called tea item 2 this is a
function so if we call that function
with the be the boolean value we get a
value of the type T so that's not quite
what we need we need a value of type T
result can we somehow translate a tea to
a tea result oh it's up there in the
selector so we can just call the
selector and now we get a tea result
from the tea so that entire lamp
expression there is a func from google
to t from pool to tier assault and it's
it looks absolutely horrible but it gets
the job done
this is actually also how you do it in F
sharp and in Haskell and basically you
know there you don't have to think this
is just this is how it's always done
there's a recipe for that you just
follow the recipe and you do that for
the two other cases and it just looks
like this so that that went that made
everything look even worse but again you
know if you don't if you're not on the
understanding all of this the point I'm
trying to make is just that this is what
your code is gonna look like if you want
to do functional programming in if inchi
sharp that is alright so um let's see
how much time do we have
okay so what we've done now we've
actually created a functor so we know
that we if we have a functor we can use
a free monad to turn any function into a
free monad so how does that work
so now I'm putting away the church
encoding recipe and I'm picking up my
you know free monad recipe again and I
will try to look at you know how does
that work so am in f-sharp you have to
then begin to type to define a type
caller reservations program so what
we've defined so far is an instruction
set
so we said there you know our DSL has
three small verbs or three small
instructions but now we would like to
create small programs using that news
that DSL so we'll define a type call
reservations program up a and it always
follows the same structure the its it
has two cases so it's a discriminated
Union the first one is called free and
in this case the type is of reservation
instruction mister
you just see in the function that we
just created off a reservation program
of a but and then you say well but wait
a minute preservation program of a
that's what you're defining right now
yeah this is a recursive tartar
definition so to get used to working
with recursion if you want to do
functional programming all right so well
how would you ever create a value like
this you say well you used to free start
a constructor and then you say well I
need to create one of those instructions
in order to do that I'll need to create
a program it also create a program I'll
need to use the free free data
constructor and then you'll just you
know keep on forever so you need you
know a way out
so there's another case here called pure
and that means if you want to create a
program you can also just say pure of
int for example you know pure of 42 and
that would give you a program of int so
you can mix those so you can say well
the free and then you can create an
instruction that inside of that has a
pure Vee you need those leaf nodes in
sort of that recursive data structure in
order to you know make it stop at some
point but this starts a time we can turn
into a motor into a monad in a moment
but first of all we need to figure out
okay so how do we encode that into sharp
so again I'm gonna put away my free
monad recipe I'm going to go back and
pick up my church encoding recipe and
say oh we know how to church encode this
because we've already seen how to do
that so we create an i reservations
program of T we add a single match
method and now I need to add two
arguments one for each case the first
one should be a func from I reservation
instruction from I reservation program
to T into T result and we call that free
and the other one should be a fun from
TTT salt and we call that pure okay
first save our church encoding the
second one is create the classes that
implement the interface in this case we
just need to I'll start with the simpler
one simplest one the pure one so pure
implements the interface it's just a net
after over the generic type T so we just
have any value of the generic type T and
we make it look like a nice reservation
program of T how do we do that well we
implement the interface there's this
match method and we always just call
cure because pure is a function that
goes from T to T resolved we already
have a T that's X so if we call that
with X we
to resolve back so that that type checks
so that's that's what we need and you
notice we completely ignore the other
argument there so we just dispatched to
that handler now in the other case it's
basically the same thing we call it free
of T the data inside of it is much more
complicated but again you can sort of
just imagine that it's you don't really
have to understand what it is we're just
having adapter over that horrible
looking thing there and then we
implement the match method again and we
do that by always calling free because
that's the only thing that will take
that type of data and return it to you
result so we just dispatched to the free
function and always ignore the pure
function right so that's how we do in
the church encoding of the of the
program type so now we have a
reservation program of T now we're
trying to figure out whether we can turn
that into a free monad so how can we
turn this into a moment what does that
mean well basically it means if we have
a reservations program of T we want to
be able to turn it into an AI
reservation program with T result you
sort of heard that's this before we say
well isn't that just a functor yeah but
the translation function is going to be
a little bit different if you have a
func from T to I reservations program of
T result if you can make that work then
you have yourself a monad so in order to
implement that will create a method
called select many so you'll notice that
you know the the type of this thing and
the naming of it is actually given by
the Chicago compiler already C sharp
knows about these things if you if you
do it right you actually get query
syntax support for your know type here
so select many is the name we make it an
extension method on reservation program
of T and we call the function there
selector just like before and basically
what we need to do is follow the types
the first thing the only thing we can do
with the source is just called match so
you see sort of we just go this is very
mechanical we just go through the same
things over and over again now the match
method takes two arguments and a
function that will handle each of the
cases so we'll start by writing a lambda
expression that handles the free case
and the free case the lambda expression
takes us input and I reservations
instruction of an i reservation program
of T now it begins
the
it's a little bit hairy now what we need
to do is we need to return our
reservations program to result and we
need to make it structure preserving so
we need to translate the free case into
another free case that we say new free
of T result so if you do that the the
visual studio or you know your IDE will
tell you that what you need to put into
that free of T result is an I
reservations instruction of an AI
reservation program of T result so you
somehow need to you know translate one
into the other
they blob of T to the blob of T result
now you have this AI reservation
instruction already and it's a functor
so we know that the Select method can
actually be used to translate the thing
inside to another thing so we call
select on that that's the extension
method that we just created before so
inside of that is a program and I
reservations program of of T so how do
you get an IRA situations program of T
results out of that well you will notice
that the method that we're writing at
the moment takes as input and I
reservations program of T and its output
and our reservations program of T result
which is exactly what we need so we're
just going to call the selector which is
just kind of course select many with the
selector and that's it so you go where
[Music]
doesn't it call itself yeah calls itself
it calls itself recursively so but the
house that Emma Connors end what it's
going to end because sooner or later is
going to run into that pure thing there
and then it's just gonna cause a pure is
T value and we just turn that into an I
reservations program of T V solve by
calling the selector and that may you
know at that point the stack can unwind
and it can go back to all those
recursive calls to select many so you
say well but still doesn't it mean that
all of that recursion couldn't you blow
the stack yep you could blow the stack
but that's not nice I know it's not nice
this is why I don't want to do
functional programming in C sharp
because eventually you will have to deal
with the recursion which is a normal
thing in functional programming
languages and languages like Haskell and
F sharp they have language they have a
language feature called tail recursion
so
if you write your recursive algorithms
in the appropriate way they never blow
the stack but she shop doesn't have that
feature so you even if you do all the
things right you could still blow the
stack so that's another reason why you
don't want to do functional programming
in C sharp but still okay in this case
you know when you're doing free monads
if the stack is intense not to get that
deep anyway and not not in this example
anyway so we can just you know push on
and see if we can get things done but
select many is now implemented and then
this means this is a monad this
basically what a monad means as we don't
have to make it you know particularly
magic this this is basically what we
need to do right so the last few things
that I need to do in order to you know
be able to complete all of this stuff is
just gonna add a few help of helper
methods so before when we use dependency
injection we had you know normal methods
that we could call like is reservation
in the future you pass in reservation to
that and that would have returned a
boolean value now what we want to do
instead is we want to say we want to be
able to create small programs snippets
of this little DSL that we are creating
at the moment so we're creating a little
helper function here that says you know
when I call is reservation in future
with the reservation I gate get one of
those program snippets and then I can
compose those with other program
snippets because it's a monad and monads
compose so if we were to do this in F
sharp it would be a one-liner you know
this is basically what that what that
function looks like in there sharp you
know translating this function to C
sharp looks like this it this is the
same but because C sharp is not really
you know designed to do all the fancy
type inferences that a sharp compiler
can do you have to do all of that type
annotations with all the generics and so
that one line that turns into all of
that the thing and the same thing goes
for the other ones if you want to create
static helper methods for the other two
cases it read reservations tend to look
like this
I'm not even gonna walk you through this
and create looks like this so you know
this as you may have noticed so far
creates quite a lot of boilerplate code
but we can now rewrite try/except
as a pure function so the idea here is
now that it takes a reservation its
input that's a pure value but instead of
just returning a nullable int it returns
an program of novel int and that means
you know that's actually a little
abstract syntax tree that describes what
you want to happen in various different
cases and then you can have you can run
an interpreter over that you know little
abstract syntax tree and then whenever
you encounter one of those instructions
you can go and query the database or
query the system clock or whatever and
that's sort of how it how it works so
this is a fairly normal thing to do in
Haskell this allows you to sort of push
all your impure you know I owe to the
boundary of the system now the way that
it ends up looking in in c-sharp then is
to say well let's start by figuring out
whether the reservation is in the future
so we call is reservation in future that
new static helper method that that I
just defined and that is not enough you
know we need to do more because this
just returns an i reservations
programmer fool but what you can do now
is you can just like in the TPL example
that I showed you before you can now say
well when this is done with that
evaluation is done and the boolean value
has been produced
I can now provide a continuation so in
the TPL example that continuation was
called continue with but now since this
is a monad we can call select many
instead and the input to the
continuation is the output from the
previous step that's just a boolean
value and that means we can now switch
and that or we can you know do an if
evaluation and that didn't say if that's
false
we'll return a new pure of knowledge int
because pure implements our reservation
program of of T so this is an our
reservation program of multiple int
purist that is now otherwise we can
continues and say well if we are not
exited at this point and we can return
we can continue with the next thing we
can call read reservations another one
of those small static helper methods
that I am that I wrote and this will
then create a program of collection of
reservation
and then you can do a continuation of
that as well and that's going to be
arias I'm not I'm not even gonna try to
attempt to talk you through this it
looks horrible and that's the point all
right
we're we're basically done but I want to
say a few more things before we wrap up
now you may say that this is an eye
reservation instruction this is a church
encoded discriminated Union you could
say that I'm building up a little bit of
a straw man or argument here because
I've made it unnecessarily functional
and it's not properly object-oriented I
can actually refactor this into
something that's more object oriented so
it turns out that this is really just a
disguise of a very well-known design
pattern you may have noticed that I said
dispatched quite a few times all that's
going on here is double dispatching so
you can refactor this to the visitor
design pattern so what you end up having
then is you have a reservation structure
T that just has a single method called
accept it's no longer called matched
it's called accept and then you have
that auxilary interface definition that
defines the visitor and it has three
methods that our handlers for all of
those three cases there's still some
inline functions there but we've
actually made it more object-oriented if
you will and we can do the same thing
with the program we can refactor that
into a visitor and we can also do it the
other way so this is what we call an
isomorphism you can always take a church
encoded and discriminate a union turn
that into a visitor you can always take
a visitor and turn it into a church and
go to discriminate Union in sort of goes
both ways there's no loss of information
going back and forth there so this is
basically why I called the talk here
dependency injection revisited the point
is that you can refactor your dependency
injection based code to just return
something that is a visitor where the
visitor walks over a little abstract
syntax tree why would want to do that
I'm I don't know I mean that would be
absolutely crazy stuff I think I just
did it because I I can and the the
try/except
myth that here doesn't change whether
you use the church encoding or whether
you use the visitor variation
it doesn't change so that just remains
the same so you may say now well but
this this seems really difficult is
functional programming is is it really
like that is it that hard and it's no
it's not you know in high school it
would look like this but this would be
it you know there would be no
boilerplate and ask well this would just
be the function that I write all the
things that I pull in all the data types
and so on there's just there's a few of
my own
you know like a reservation for example
is still you know my own domain type and
but apart from that turning that into
free monad is just one line of
declaration saying here I have something
I'll turn it into a free moment bang
it's done and I can write code against
that there's no polar plate there and
you can do the same thing in if sharp
you that requires a little bit more
boilerplate because there are things you
know you can't automatically do an F
sharp that you can do in high school but
it still looks fairly pretty I think now
I did say that in c-sharp you know by
writing select many in the appropriate
way you could use query syntax this is
basically what we're doing here we're
sort of blazing the monnet you know fade
into the background because we have some
you know syntactic sugar in Haskell and
in F sharp so we could say well but we
do have syntactic sugar in c-sharp as
well we can use it we can use query
syntax so we could rewrite the
try/except function to look something
like this so these this uses you know
query syntax you'll notice that all of
these return
blah blah blah from returned from blah
blah blah in blah blah blah from blah
blah blah in blah blah blah and so on so
this works but but it's not pretty
and you know I had to stack monads in
order to make it work because one
limitation of the c-sharp query syntax
support is that it doesn't allow
arbitrary branching inside of the you
know the query syntax so in order to
deal with branching I had to you know
turn the inaudible into an ax maybe
which is a monad in its own right and
then I had to define a stack of you know
those two monads which would you know
resulted in even more boilerplate code
so just grows and grows and grows and
grows and then even so it's not really
pretty because you have to resort to
using those underscores and double
underscores and so on in order
to get the code to compile so um I would
say that this works it it executes it
compiles it it is the way you can do it
but I'd you know if if you if you hire a
new developer and you know your manager
says well I've hired this new developer
she or he has you know ten years
experience with she sharp so she or he's
gonna fit right in and you say well okay
here's the code this is our code base
you know go figure you know it's not you
know it's not the syntax the syntax
doesn't really help you here knowing the
c-sharp syntax because the abstractions
are completely alien to what you know
compared to what most people are used to
so how do I do functional programming
it's a sharp
well you don't because she shop is an
object-oriented language fine its
object-oriented but it has slammed us
how do I write strictly functional code
well you use Church encoding to make
illegal states all representable well
can you just tell me to go myself
but if I did pop so the point that I'm
trying to make here is not you know
c-sharp has many good features and some
of them were inspired by functional
programming like lambda and like link
and things like that and I'm not saying
you shouldn't use those features the
c-sharp language design team very
carefully picks those features that that
they think fits into the C sharp
language and they port those things over
and there are other things that sort of
leaving a 1 on the F sharp side or the
Haskell side because it doesn't really
fit the language so using the things
that are there you know in c-sharp I
think is perfectly fine and so I'm not
trying to say that you shouldn't adopt
some sort of hybrid approach but if you
really want to do functional programming
you you have to realize that c-sharp is
not the environment for that because
it's not designed to do that if you
really want to do functional programming
you should really use a proper language
for that and I understand that it can be
difficult because you you and uh no
because the organization and you have
managers and so on but still I think it
makes it makes no sense to try to do it
in c-sharp it would make sense to do it
in other languages I would I really love
functional programming but it needs to
be in the right language so
I'll stop talking if you have questions
I'll be happy to answer the questions I
think you can just come and talk to me
if you have and those of you who want to
get lunch a little bit earlier than
anyone else and you should just you know
rush out of the door now but please
remember to fill in or you put the
evaluation things in when you leave so
thank you for coming and have a great
conference in today or tomorrow
[Applause]